[Musique]
ml maisonneuve bonjour merci d'être sur
le plateau de tv 68 poursuivi qui vous
ira entièrement consacré vous êtes
conservateur du patrimoine vous êtes
directrice du musée en guinée à
versailles et vous êtes vous êtes la
commissaire de l'exposition trésors
cachés du musée lambinet qui a lieu en
ce moment à l'espace richaud à
versailles d'ailleurs on peut déjà dire
les dates
ça a commencé du 20 septembre au 17
novembre
voilà la raison de votre présence ici
tout à fait je remercie de me recevoir
mais c'est un grand plaisir déjà on va
pouvoir faire connaissance avec vous
parce que vous êtes depuis combien de
temps directrice du musée lambinet
depuis presque amant d'accord donc c'est
encore tout frais et avant vous étiez ou
alors j'ai dirigé le musée d'art et
d'histoire de meudon n'est autrefois
j'étais au musée de saint maur des
fossés d'accord alors est ce qu'on peut
pour ceux qui ne connaîtraient pas
définir un peu le musée lambinet déjà
aidé sur l'architecturé à sculpter le
musée lambinet doc est installé dans un
hôtel particulier du xviiie siècle un
goût et c'est en fait le musée
d'histoire de la ville de versailles
d'accord et nos collections donc tourner
autour du xviiie siècle bien sûr mais
aussi en fait tout ce qui a trait à la
ville de versailles depuis en gros le
moyen âge jusqu'à nos jours
vaches en que notre coeur de collection
c'est quand même du 17e au 19e siècle
d'accord vous avez des objets du moyen
âge un peu faible voilà des choses à
redécouvrir justement dans les
collections et en se positionne vraiment
comme un musée de collectionneurs
puisque cette fois je vais vous demander
plus que ça veut dire à monsieur
collectionneurs en fait nos collections
avons été offerte légué donné par des
collectionneurs attaché à la ville de
versailles
donc tout d'abord à la bibliothèque
municipale qui nous a transformé une
partie de ses collections
et puis encore aujourd'hui moi j'ai
régulièrement encore des propositions
bientôt au musée lambinet tech
justaucorps avec schering d'un coq ça il
veut dire qu'il ya régulièrement des
nouvelles oeuvres
aller exactement j'ai tout cas moi voilà
des propos d'un squale intéressante oui
c'est fou d'accord et alors vous avez
donc ses collections permanentes et vous
avez aussi des expositions ponctuelles à
l'envi ne suis pas d'accord
en moyenne deux expositions par an non
mais c'est vrai que cette exposition la
l'espace richaud sa part s'est rajouté
d'accord et là en ce moment à lambiner
une exposition pas pour le moment on va
ouvrir la prochaine début novembre ce
sera et ce sera donc 100 portraits pour
un siècle et c'est qu'une collection en
fait particulière d'un portrait
peintures et pastels du xviiie siècle et
c'est un commissaire d'exposition du
musée du louvre qui viendra donc assurée
l'exposition le catalogue d'accord bon
on en reparlera alors exact sera
l'occasion
voilà alors l'actualité volante de danse
moment justement c'est cette fameuse
expo trésors cachés du musée lambinet
alors comment vous avez eu cette idée je
dis juste ce qui me paraissait un peu
étrange et pas ordinaire justement
c'était que le musée lambinet ça a un
petit côté cosy intime on est on est
dans une maison certes grande mais voyez
ce que je dis et réchaud c'est tout
l'opposé parce que l'espace riche en
général reçoit des grands formats
oui parce qu'en fait maastricht chaud
donc été en fait la chapelle de l'ancien
hôpital royal bénéficie en effet d'un
espace majestueux avec justement c'est
cette coupole pourrait libérer sa part
donc voilà et l'idée en fait été de 2
nous permettre de poser un regard
différent sur nos collections d'accord
on m'a proposé justement de mener cette
exposition dans un temps assez court
donc notre sélection en fait s'est porté
sur une cinquantaine de pièces a plus
rien et le propos était en fait de
magnifier ces pièces de les mettre
vraiment en valeur en les sortant
justement de leur contexte
de tels particulier au musée lambinet
d'accord donc tous deux s'étaient
d'abord les espaces autour de chaque
pièce pour qu'elle soit vraiment la
cible en dhr prendre le temps de les
observer prendre le temps de les
contempler sans le
de les étudier aux i pour nous donc on
sait en fait
attaché à montrer des oeuvres à la fois
en réserve donc fragile précieuse qu'on
sort très peu souvent
et puis des oeuvres qui sont en fait
dans parcours permanent mais qui sont
plutôt un peu comme un décor
voilà devant lesquels ont pas si on
s'arrête pas et là ça va vraiment très
bien fonctionné puisque j'ai vu beaucoup
de gens qui me disaient ah bon mais il y
avait cette oeuvre au musée
oui oui elle était temps parcours
permanent ami l'avait pas remarqué
donc la mise en espace du coup change le
regard donc vous avez sélectionné panon
50 eur et du coup il a fallu inventer
une scénographie parce que le jeu ne se
prête pas aux parce qu'il ya quand même
pas mal d'objets d'art des meubles des
choses qu'on ne voit pas d'habitude aux
mollahs helvètes on a fait une
expression entièrement en interne avec
juste les services de la ville en fête
qui ont fait un travail merveilleux
on a par exemple à serrurier qui nous a
créé vraiment une vitrine absolument
sublime et c'est ma collègue alice
gamblin qui est chargé de la régie des
oeuvres qui a conçu alors la régie en
fait c'est l'aspect matériel de leur
envoyer quand on déplace un objet c'est
la richesse des collections thivel
justement à son transport à la
conservation fait que valence soudan et
donc c'est cette personne en fait aidé
de l'administrateur des laisses pas très
chaud qui ont conçu l'exposition à ma
demande d'accord donc notamment pour les
objets précieux donc désormais précieux
qui sont pas forcément visibles
l'ensemble est dommage par exemple
quelques miniatures c'est dommage c'est
vrai mais là c'est pour ça qu'il faut
absolument voir ce qu'on allait voir
ensuite on va les rues ranger en réserve
ah oui pour quelques mois voire
peut-être quelques années d'accord et
vote réservé ou alors elle est dans les
espaces du musée
mais ces pièces là elle ne tourne pas
justement parfois demande en exposition
on va quand même de demande de prêt
quand même les collections tournoi on
tourne bien mais un dessin par exemple
vous pouvez les sortir trois mois tous
les trois ans d'abord on lui offre sa
voix y ait une règle c'est l'exhortation
voilà pour essayer de préserver au mieux
les collections et notamment les
collections fragile si nos salles et
halter ou ce jusqu ici ça désaltère bien
sûr les secondaires voilà d'accord c'est
d'autant plus intéressant d'y aller
parce qu'il ya certains descendent
notamment un dessin qui représente sur
l'autre cordée qui est en fait le
portrait que jean-jacques hour a pu
faire d'elle seule artiste autorisés à
aller dans sa prison avant a fait un
portrait et sachant que l été exécuté
quelques jours après son procès oui
c'est vraiment un témoignage là aussi un
trésor historique on d'accord donc qu'on
ne voit pas d'habitude d'accord voilà
c'est si trop fragile et c'est vraiment
précieux c'est très rare le château le
château de versailles à une peinture
mais nous on a vraiment lieu de l'ordre
social d'accord ok donc on va je vous
propose qu'on fasse un peu une visite
alors je crois quand on arrive à
l'espèce richaud on est accueilli par
une harpe absolument magnifique et
somptueuse qui est un peu le point
d'orgue de l'expo en effet c'est l'objet
que j'ai choisie qui pour moi représente
est vraiment le musée en fait le musée
lambinet c'est un objet d'art un objet
en fait du quotidien puisque les femmes
voilà pouvait jouer de la musique tous
les jours dans leur salon
et par ailleurs quand on se penche un
peu sur son histoire en découvre que
sina dorman lüthi de marie antoinette
qui l'a conçu sachant qu'en france il ya
très peu de harpe de nador man il y en a
une actuellement au louvre une au
château de versailles mais ça reste
vraiment quelque chose de très rare et
c'est un objet trépied dessus par sa
décoration avec du vernis burgondes donc
justement là à l'image on voit un détail
de cette fameuse art exactement
extrêmement travaillées alors c'était
l'armée marie-antoinette sans doute pas
parce que marie antoinette avait avait
une autre harper a priori ce n'est pas
là ne change pas de america est le même
on cherche pas de l'art comme ça c'est
le même même artiste ces mêmes artisans
ou alors ils veulent et qui était un an
vraiment très reconnu à l'époque très
inquiet je vous ai coupé la parole et
sur six mois donc cet objet c'est
vraiment l'emblème on le voit d'habitude
on voit pas non plus il est en plein
milieu du salon
mais je pense que les visiteurs passent
un peu à côté ça fait partie de la
seconde journée autour et on peut voir
vraiment toute la signature en fait du
luthier voir ce vernis matin de près par
qui se servait un email alors en fait
c'est de la peinture couvert de
multiples couches de vernis qui donne un
aspect comme ça très particulier très
brillant et en fait ça il cherché à
copier justement les lacs du japon et
avec un côté beaucoup plus frais je
trouve beaucoup plus joyeux que d'accord
aux japonais très bien alors donc ça
c'est la pièce phare qui est donc sous
la coupole en larmes
voilà fois ci sans socle on a vraiment
laissé comme ça parce qu'un seul ray
show est conçu de telle manière que le
lieu se suffit à lui-même
et en fait on a choisi de laisser la
rep' nu juste avec une mise à distance
pour la mise au vert
très bien après on va parler d'autres
pièces qui sont donc visibles
vous avez cette fameuse assiette voilà
qui a paradé correctement de hubert
robert donc
un peintre du xviiie siècle qui a été en
fait emprisonner en 1793 et qui dans sa
prison avait quand même des conditions
de détention à ces plats chauds ailleurs
c'était un vip non qu'ils avaient
reconstitué tout une petite vie sociale
et hubert robert continue de peindre et
voyez en fait sur cette oeuvre
on n'a pas l'impression d'être dans un
univers carcéral plutôt une scène un peu
la vie quotidienne ses cousines chasse
et poésie alors que quelqu'un est en
train d'écrire sur le registre le nom
des condamnés ah oui c'est moins drôle
c'est moins drôle et donc dans cette
prison en fait eu mais robert avait
carrément développer un commerce
donc il avait en fait un peu soudoyer le
portier pour vendre ses assiettes à des
collectionneurs français et anglais il
est d'accord sont parvenus voilà jusqu'à
nous et on en a une au musée lambinet
intérieur
c'est incroyable c'est vrai que on
pourrait là aussi passer à côté parce
que c'est mon année les grands c'est sur
un objet un peu particulier mais en fait
c'est très trottoir mais une vraie
histoire et comment aimer quelqu'un très
joyeux quelqu'un de sportif
il avait en fait choisi de montrer les
choses plus tôt enfin pas trop triste
ont fait d'accord je te jure ventes
d'accor après on a d'autres alors ça
qu'est-ce que ça c'est magnifique c'est
la ligue fellaini tu vois la vie laïque
donc grands créateurs de verre qui
d'abord avait passé de nombreuses années
crée des bijoux magnifiques notamment
pour les actrices comme sarah bernhardt
et là c'est une autre actrice alors là
on lui a promis aux xviie et au xviiie
voilà les fans 9,1 19h 1899 julien
barthe et qui avait moins travaillé à sa
gloire personnelle que sarah bernhardt
qu moins connue était une grande
comédienne de la comédie française et
avait remis au goût du jour bérénice et
pour justement une des multiples
représentations ce qu'elle a quand même
joué 80 fois ce rôle elle avait demandé
à rené lalique donc de lui créer un
diadème qui montre ce côté oriental
puisque bérénice et une reine de
palestine vont donc vous avez ces
références à lorient et l'utilisation en
même temps de matériaux nouveaux
avec de l'étain la cornaline etc qui
sont moins précieuse mais qui se
comprennent bien justement dans un
dans une pièce de théâtre est d'accord
donc ça c'est un objet qui n'est pas
très grand qui n'est pas très anglais
voilà qui tient sur la tête il n'est pas
très très lourd en fait mais qui est
très précieux très intéressant à double
titre pour nous parce que juillet
barthet et aussi une grande donatrice du
musée lambinet c'est vrai voilà ce qu'en
1942 elle a donné beaucoup d'oeuvres du
xviiie siècle au musée vous écouter on
en soit remercié alors ensuite nous
avons une dernière offre et après
l'émission e je pense sera terminée
voilà qui cette petite fille alors cette
petite fille est alexandrine la fille de
madame de pompadour qui était son père
alors son père était donc le mari
légitime
voilà que de madame de pompadour et en
fait alexandrine et est décédé très tôt
en fait avant l'âge de dix ans d'une
crise un panier site
madame de badauds l'a fait venir à la
cour à l'âge de 20 ans il ya très peu de
portraits d'elle le château de
versailles acheté récemment un portrait
par boucher une peinture est en fait
notre miniature on reprend ce portrait
donc c'est un tout petit objet sachant
donc les miniatures et des objets qu'on
portait sur soient d'accord n'emmener
c'était vraiment les objets intimes a
dit voilà donc c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est celle dimension à la
voix intime dans un cadre plutôt gigon
texte par rapport à l'objet et qui donne
un nouveau regard et qui permet donc de
mettre en lumière des oeuvres d'art très
précieuse que près six mois quasiment
tout un fake précieuses et méconnues
voilà c'est très joli bond merci mais
les maisons neuves d'être venu bien
donner vraiment envie d'aller voir cette
très belle exposition et à très bientôt
au musée lambinet ou sait jamais très
bientôt pour la prochaine expression
avec grand plaisir merci la mairie
[Musique]